[Music]
back here at home right now a murder
investigation in central las vegas metro
police say a landlord is in custody
accused of shooting and killing two
tenants during a dispute over unpaid
rent
this happened overnight near chicago and
industrial just north of sahara and
that's where hector mejia is live to
tell us what he knows about this crime
at this hour
[Music]
right now we're still waiting for
authorities to release the name of the
people involved but right now actually
just a few seconds ago
metro police removed the crime scene
tape that was blocking
the entrance into this home they left
out a walker here at the foot of the
driveway but this home
is where they've been focusing their
investigation since last night for
several hours here scouring for evidence
this neighborhood is just north of the
strat the early morning shooting left
two women dead and a man with critical
injuries here
the shooter in custody police say is the
landlord
and they believe this may have started
as a dispute over unpaid rent
the victims were tenants who lived at
the home where the shooting happened
and officers described a gruesome scene
when they arrived they said when they
first got to the scene
they found the body of a woman outside
then they saw a man with nine gunshot
wounds coming out of the home
it wasn't until the suspect the
suspected shooter surrendered to police
that they discovered the second body of
a woman
that second body was found inside of the
home a neighbor told us it makes him sad
to hear about
violence happening yet again in this
neighborhood
too many people just are too violent
too many weapons that they can just go
out every time they want to resolve an
issue
they put each other on blasts they don't
discuss anything
they don't talk to anything they just go
shoot each other
this happens way too often
in this tiny little community of 12
blocks
in naked city
we are also learning that the landlord
may have lived at the same residence and
we are waiting to find out the name of
the person in custody
the clark county coroner's office will
release the name of the two victims once
their families are notified but back out
here
we still have some police presence
remaining here at the scene
as they wrap up their investigation
we'll have the latest later on
on 8 news now at 4 p.m reporting live
hector mejia
8 news